as you all know trooper micah may will
be laid to rest later this morning he
died
after being hit by a carjacking suspect
on the i-15 during a chaotic
police chase he was laying down spike
strips trying to stop the suspect's
rampage
so here's a look at how the community
will remember him
paying tribute to nevada highway patrol
trooper micah may
the 46 year old was killed in the line
of duty on july 27
while trying to stop a suspected
carjacker the trooper fought for his
life at umc
hospital but did not survive it left the
local law enforcement community
devastated it's these tragic situations
like this where
you really realize that las vegas is a
community it's a community that cares
trooper may was a husband and father of
two young children
on tuesday hundreds gathered at police
memorial park in the northwest valley
for a candlelight vigil may's wife
shared how much he loved his family
and how proud he was to protect and
serve the community michael loved his
job
and he loved being a straight trooper he
found great joy
in taking bad people off the road i know
that he gave his life doing what he
loved he
came to work every day and he did his
job but yet when the chips were down he
was the first guy responding and the
first person on scene
the procession will begin at 9 30 at
palm mortuary on main street
it will end at central church where the
funeral service starts
at 11. heard again there will be several
road closures
for this morning's procession we're
going to send it over to hector who has
a look at those so you can plan out your
day hector
hey there bianca it'll be a really
difficult day for all of our law
enforcement and the first responders
community here in the valley
so it all starts at 9 30 this morning
ndot says prepare significant delays
the procession will go from downtown
from palm mortuary starting at 9 30 this
morning
it'll get onto the i-15 get off on
spring mountain road
and then travel down las vegas boulevard
before getting on the beltway in the
south at 2 15.
eventually it will go northbound on the
95 515 over for central christian church
then right about around one o'clock in
the evening
one pm it'll basically take the same
route it'll go southbound on the 95
it'll come back on the 215 and then get
off on warm springs road
for the gravesite that starts at 1pm